Harold asks Gary what is your view on
franchising your company when you can't
be sure if others will care for the
brand in the same way Harold it's a
great question I think the real answer
to that needs one more layer of context
when you say franchising your business
if you're building a consumer facing
business a retailer q sr or restaurant
then you franchising is a tremendous
model we've seen it from McDonald's to
Five Guys sonic I mean it's a great
thing to do it's the right business
model or it's a phenomenal version of
the right business model you can go
private if you want what I'm concerned
about what I don't know and Indiana and
really ask you is show India everybody's
probably missing India that you can get
the little camera time is are you going
down the route of like selling your name
the reason I'm asking that and I don't
know if you could figure it out from the
question a lot of people trying to
franchise me I know there's a lot of
gurus and advise people where like they
teach the the amount of people that
pitched me when I was out of heat in
2010 on the idea of a Gary Vaynerchuk
crush it course and they would be the
person like teaching and it would siphon
back up to me that was something I
wasn't comfortable with because it
wasn't something that I felt represented
me and I wouldn't want to franchise that
route and so if you're asking that
that's super uncomfortable to me
somebody representing you a big concern
of mine as far as like a retailer or a
restaurant I feel super comfortable with
that many people have pulled off you
know making sure the brand was insured
by lots of rules lots of legal jargon
lots of training or whatever it took to
scale that anything from your end you
get anything there all right so that's
the answer I give you both oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe